The first thing I ask every storyteller,
personal storyteller or business is who
is the audience? And about half the time
they don't know, which is crazy. You
have to know who you're talking to. You
have to know what your audience is going
to be before you figure out what to say.
One Super Bowl commercial nailed this
perfectly and another one failed
miserably. Let's take a look at each
one.
The opening shot is of a flag in the
mountains and the landscapes.
Longest thing we ever do is live our
lives.
But life doesn't come with an owner's
manual. Harrison Ford.
Harrison Ford is an actor that every
single human being likes. He is
perfectly universal and perfect for this
commercial. And notice how as the
commercial opens you don't quite know
who it is. They open with a side view
which creates suspense. Who is it? And
then you hear the voice first and you
think I know that voice.
>> [music]
>> But life doesn't come with an owner's
>> then he turns and you see who it is and
manual.
you feel like you're at home. It's
Harrison Ford. Everything he says I will
believe.
Might have been nice, huh?
But that [music] means we get to write
our own stories.
Freedom is
yes
or [music] no
or
maybe.
That's all of the commercial right
there.
We're going to be speaking to two
different audiences. Essentially, this
is a commercial for two kinds of people.
It is for Jeep owners that want to put
gasoline in their machines and drive
into the mountains and tear up the
ground and have a great time. And it's
also for Jeep owners who want to buy an
electric vehicle and quietly drive down
the street to the store. That is
literally what this commercial is
speaking to. It's speaking to both
audiences simultaneously and they're
using Harrison Ford to say basically
both are fine, we're all good.
Freedom is for everybody.
But it isn't [music] free.
It's earned.
So we flash to some World War footage
because everyone agrees that World War
vets are to be admired and respected at
all costs.
They're our real heroes. Note here that
a dog appears, the only other character
in the story. We put a dog into the
story because along with the flag and
World War vets, dogs are something we
agree upon almost more than we agree
upon that Harrison Ford is
extraordinary. We throw the dog in
because everyone loves a dog.
But not the ones in the movies.
Real heroes are humble.
They're not driven by pride.
Harrison Ford says that real heroes are
not in the movies. He's basically saying
I'm not a hero, which makes us think
he's a hero. And Harrison Ford is making
a simple statement that we all agree to.
Real heroes are not driven by pride.
They are humble and we get a flash of
another veteran coming home and hugging
his daughter. Freedom is the roar. One
man's
>> And now we get two Jeeps.
We get the one without doors that you
drive in the mountains with gas.
And we get Harrison Ford driving an
electric vehicle right next to it. The
two of them are equal, the two of them
are fine, everyone is good.
>> You don't have to be friends with
someone to wave at them. You don't have
to be friends with someone to wave at
them. And at that moment the electric
vehicle and the gas vehicle, they pass
each other and Harrison Ford is
basically saying it's okay if we
disagree, we can still wave at each
other.
We won't always agree on which way to
go.
But our differences can be our strength.
[music]
>> Our differences can be our strength. I
can buy an electric vehicle, you can buy
a gas-powered vehicle and that's going
to be our strength. And the way those
two Jeeps pass each other and the trails
form a V with one going in one
direction, one going the other
direction, but they're all driving,
they're all in a Jeep. They're thinking
entirely about the audience and speaking
to two different groups of people
simultaneously and highly effectively.
So choose, but choose wisely. [music]
Choose what makes you happy. We get the
picture of an electric vehicle being
unplugged, which is great for Jeep,
simple to use, plug it in, plug it out.
We get an image of a Jeep.
My friends, my family
my work [music] make me happy. My
friends, my family, my work make me
happy first and then this Jeep [music]
makes me happy. Jeep is smart. It's the
fourth thing. It's not the first thing.
Even though my name is
Even though my name is Ford, which is a
joke, and then the only other character
in the commercial speaks a tiny bit,
which is the dog, makes a little whine
as if to indicate the joke wasn't funny.
>> [music]
>> That's my owner's manual.
Get out there.
Write your own. [music]
And at the end of the commercial we're
right back where we began. At the
beginning of the commercial Harrison
Ford is at a fireplace [music] saying
wouldn't it be nice if life had an
owner's manual. And at the end of the
commercial he says that's my owner's
manual. Get out there, write your own.
In other words, buy a Jeep. This is a
commercial that understands audience and
knows exactly who they are speaking to.
>> [snorts]
>> Now I'm going to talk about a commercial
that fails when it comes to audience.
And oddly enough I am the audience for
this commercial. I grew up 30 minutes
south of Boston. I am a Patriot season
ticket holder. I watched the Celtics win
the championship in the Fleet Center
last year. I am Boston through and
through. So I am the audience for this
commercial and the problem is
I am the audience for this commercial.
It's a Super Bowl commercial and it's
targeting essentially me
and not the country.
The first problem with it before I even
hit start is the fact that it's a
sequel. It's a sequel to a commercial
from last year which suffers from the
curse of knowledge because we have now
had 365
days to forget about the commercial we
saw last year and now we're picking up
where it left off. This makes no sense
whatsoever. There should not be a sequel
in the Super Bowl commercial unless that
commercial ran ubiquitously,
ubiquitously, ubiquitously all year
long. So the sequel is a terrible idea
already. You're going to lose half the
people who don't know what the hell is
going on.
But let's take a look at the commercial
now. Welcome to Java Jet, Battle of the
Coffee Brand Battle.
So we've got a whole bunch of people who
just flashed across the screen and I'm
wondering who are those people? Am I
supposed to know them? But one of the
biggest problems with this commercial is
there's a whole bunch of people in it.
Some of them I recognize like Ben
Affleck and I kind of recognize Casey
Affleck but I don't really cuz he's got
giant glasses on. So the whole time I'm
looking at it and going is that Casey
Affleck in that hat and those orange
glasses? Probably cuz he's sitting next
to Ben. And I know it looking at this
now that Bill Belichick is standing
behind him and I know who Bill Belichick
is because
you know, I sat in that stadium for the
last 22 years and I honor Bill Belichick
and I know who he is. But wait, I hope
other people know who he is. This is the
first problem with the commercial. The
audience is everywhere meaning they're
throwing out tons of references, pop
culture and instead of hoping to sort of
hit somebody with one of the references,
they're confusing me. I'm wondering who
all these people are. They're thinking
well he got Belichick, isn't he good? He
got Affleck, isn't he good? No, he's not
because he's confused about all these
other people. We get them suckers. Matt
Damon and Tom Brady don't have that hot
of a champion. We got a new squad,
Dunkings sequel, Afflecks and Belichick.
Dunkings.
Dunkings sequel. So if you don't
remember the commercial from last year,
we have a sequel and this is the moment
where you go what do you mean Dunkings
sequel?
Little more spirit on the you know on
the charge next time?
We got a fourth Dunking two coming. We
have a fourth Dunking coming. I
identified who this person is by
actually putting their name on the door
that is about to open. It's Jeremy
Strong.
If you have to put someone's name
essentially on them, you are already
worried that people don't know who the
hell this guy is, right? It's Jeremy
Strong. Do you know who Jeremy Strong
is? You might. You might know who Jeremy
Strong is if you watch Succession or
maybe one of his films, but probably
Succession. But it turns out that
Succession was only on HBO Max. So if
you didn't own HBO Max, you don't know
who the hell this guy is and I didn't
even know he was related to Boston. And
I am a Boston guy. This guy does not
have a Boston accent, he has nothing
about him that says Boston to me, but
he's going to be in this commercial now.
And so
Jeremy Strong emerges from a vat of
coffee beans, which means if I don't
know who Jeremy Strong is based upon his
name,
I'm never going to see his face and
understand who he is. If I could see his
face I'd go oh, it's that actor. It's
that guy in Succession or that guy in a
movie I saw. But he's covered in coffee
beans. So if I'm trying to figure out
how I know Jeremy Strong because I'm a
ordinary American that doesn't watch
everything on television and I don't see
every movie, I have no idea who this guy
is. Oh my god. Hey man.
>> I'm looking at him now.
He's indiscernible. You've actually
managed to get Jeremy Strong in your
commercial and make him indiscernible.
This is not understanding your audience.
If you open your commercial, a
one-minute commercial with me wondering
if it's Casey Affleck, that's what my
mind is occupied by, right? We're
distracting the audience by throwing so
many references at them that they're
trying to keep up. It is cognitively
disturbing. And now we have a guy who we
might know if we could actually see his
face and a vat of coffee beans, but we
don't know who the hell he is.
What are you doing in there? I'm just
trying to find the character. All in for
Dunkin.
Now, the one thing I do like that they
do is the opponents are wearing a green
uniform. They can't put Starbucks on
their commercial or they get sued to
high heaven, right? But they have done a
good job of making it clear that it is
Dunkin's versus Starbucks. And living in
a town where the Starbucks and the
Dunkin are literally across the street
from each other, this they have done at
least slightly well. But I'll tell you
as this scene progresses Roasted. Like a
dark seasonal roast with coriander and
slight balsamic drizzle.
>> Sounds like what's in my garbage
disposal. That was the funniest line in
the whole thing. See you, coach. How
much do we have to wait to half an hour
to get my name spelled wrong on the cup?
Nobody wants a goat milk double half-caf
soy milk cap. You could just brew it.
It's beans and water. Oh, damn.
Listen, Dunkin's for all of yous. That's
it. Dunkin is for all of yous. That is
the whole point of the commercial,
right? It took them forever to get to
the idea that Dunkin is for all of yous.
And the only way they made that point
was essentially Casey Affleck said,
"Nobody wants your coffee. It's just
beans and water." Essentially, the whole
commercial comes down to the idea that
coffee is nothing but beans and water.
Therefore,
you should go to Dunkin' Donuts. That is
it. They undermine the idea of what
coffee is, beans and water, nothing
more. And therefore, because of that,
Dunkin' Donuts is the best because
because we have Bill Belichick and Casey
Affleck and Ben Affleck and some people
I still can't figure out who the hell
they are. That's not a great message.
When your company's message about the
product you make is, "It's kind of
nothing. It's just beans and water."
That doesn't make me think, "Well, hell,
I got to go get the Dunkin' Donuts beans
and water." They throw a whole bunch of
things on the screen and they hope that
something resonates with you. Jeep
presents a clear, clean, obvious message
from a single spokesperson who everyone
knows and who everyone trusts.
This commercial, this Dunkin' Donuts
commercial, it is a mistake.
It fails to take account for audience.
That is the difference between these two
commercials and that is what we must do
as storytellers first and foremost.
Before you open your mouth or put your
pen to the page or your fingers to the
keys, the first thing you ask yourself
is who is your audience.
And then you craft a message that that
audience will listen to, believe, and
understand. Jeep did it brilliantly.
Dunkin' Donuts failed.